you have to check out these cute holiday  cookies Baker David loves being able to  provide fun and festive treats that  people can give to their loved ones or  for themselves this holiday season while  working full-time in Corporate America  he told BuzzFeed his side business has  allowed him to create and design new  things every week David also shared that  baking and decorating is therapeutic and  it's a way to keep himself grounded in  the future he hopes to inspire others to  make cookies or bring joy through his  videos to check out more videos visit  add baked dot by dot date by the way  which cookie was your favorite mine was  all of them  [Music]  foreign